This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. San Franciscans have a healthy pride in their city. Maybe their pride is a little too healthy, sometimes a little over the top, but they acknowledge this. It's the natural result of living in the greatest city in the history of the universe, they'll say. But even the most die-hard San Francisco has to admit, it could be better. Like if there was a finicular transport suspended from a bridge of soaring towers over the bay, connecting downtown San Francisco to Oakland.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。旧金山人对自己的城市有一种健康的自豪感。也许这种自豪感有时过于强烈，甚至有点夸张，但他们自己也承认这一点。他们会说，这是生活在宇宙历史上最伟大的城市所带来的自然结果。但即使是最死忠的旧金山人也不得不承认，这座城市本可以变得更好。比如，如果海湾上空有一座悬挂在巍峨塔楼之间的缆车，连接着旧金山市中心和奥克兰，那该多好。
And this basically looks like a blimp that would be attached to the underside of a bay bridge that would apparently cross the bay in five minutes. That's Allison, area of talking. She writes about designed for New York Times and is a content strategist at Spur, a member organization dedicated to crafting smart solutions for cities.
这看起来就像是一个飞艇，挂在海湾大桥的下方，显然可以在五分钟内横跨海湾。那是艾莉森·阿里亚斯（Allison Arieff）在说话。她为《纽约时报》撰写关于设计的文章，同时也是SPUR的内容策略师，这是一个致力于为城市制定智能解决方案的会员组织。
She and I are looking at an article from the April 17, 1910 edition of the San Francisco call. Fletcher Feltz proposal with the most amazing headline from the call building to Oakland City Hall in five minutes. Subtitle, who put up $16 million so that Fletcher Feltz can span the bay with his suspended auto motor railway, which promises to revolutionize all kinds of traffic by rail. The article goes on as follows. I'm going to use my old-timey reporter voice here. It will be a case of on-again off-again.
她和我正在查看1910年4月17日版《旧金山呼声报》（San Francisco Call）上的一篇文章。弗莱彻·费尔茨（Fletcher Feltz）的提案，标题极其惊人：“从呼声报大楼到奥克兰市政厅仅需五分钟”。副标题是：“谁投入了1600万美元，让弗莱彻·费尔茨能用他的悬挂式自动机车铁路跨越海湾，并承诺彻底改变各种铁路交通？”文章接着写道。我要用我那老派记者的口吻来读：这将是一次断断续续的旅程。
For you have scarcely made yourself comfortable in your seat when burr, buzz, buzz. You are flying across the bay in midair with the speed of a gun projectile, and almost before you can say, Jack Robinson, you have landed in the Athens of the Pacific. Now that's rather a startling statement, isn't it? But for Flace E. Feltz, who has looked into the future, says we are going to have such a railway. Oh, for sure, you say contemptuously. It's only a dream. Would you know some dreams come true? Um, and they just don't write them like that anymore, do they?
因为你还没在座位上坐稳，就听见“嗡、嗡、嗡”的声音。你正以炮弹般的速度飞越海湾，几乎在你还没来得及说“杰克·罗宾逊”（Jack Robinson）之前，你就已经降落在了“太平洋的雅典”。这真是一个令人震惊的声明，不是吗？但弗莱彻·E·费尔茨（Fletcher E. Feltz）展望了未来，他说我们将会拥有这样一条铁路。哦，肯定会有的，你轻蔑地说。那只是个梦。你知道吗，有些梦真的会成真？嗯，他们现在不再那样写文章了，不是吗？
Which would have been absolutely amazing if that had happened. This is one that I really wish it had happened. Yeah, so this is exactly, exactly. This is like the hyperloop of its day. So, and I'm quite sad that it didn't happen. These are stories of the unbuilt structures, a subject which has really captured the imagination of the public recently.
如果那件事真的发生了，那绝对会非常了不起。这是我真心希望能够实现的一个项目。是的，没错，确实如此。这就像是那个时代的“超级高铁”（Hyperloop）。所以，我很遗憾它没有实现。这些是关于“未建成建筑”的故事，这个主题最近确实抓住了公众的想象力。
Unbuilt San Francisco was a series of events and exhibits exploring the things that almost made it, and the effect it would have had on the city. And there was also a huge exhibit called Never Built The story and the things that almost made it, and the effect it would have had on the city. And there was also a huge exhibit called Never Belt in Los Angeles exploring the same themes. In the classification of Unbelt Structures, I put Fletcher E. Feltz's suspended auto-motor railway in a group I call Jetsons. The retro-future pictures are super cool, and they remind us when we used to drain big.
“未建成的旧金山”是一系列探索那些差点实现的项目及其对城市影响的活动和展览。还有一个名为“从未建成：洛杉矶”（Never Built Los Angeles）的大型展览，探讨了同样的主题。在“未建成建筑”的分类中，我把弗莱彻·E·费尔茨的悬挂式自动机车铁路归入了我称之为“杰森一家”（Jetsons）的类别。这些复古未来的图片超级酷，它们提醒我们曾经是多么敢于梦想。
But in the parallel universe of unbuilt structures in San Francisco, the big fish that got away, the white whale for the urban planning nerds, was a city plan from the creator of the white city. For a pure San Francisco, the one that got away was the Daniel Burnham Plan for San Francisco. That San Francisco Chronicle Architecture Critic, John King. Daniel Burnham was a Chicago architect who oversaw construction of the White City at the 1893 Colombian Exposition in Chicago. That world's fare brought about the city beautiful movement in America. The city beautiful movement with big civic centers
但在旧金山未建成建筑的平行宇宙中，那个溜走的大鱼，那个让城市规划书呆子们魂牵梦绕的“白鲸”，是一个来自“白城”创造者的城市规划。对于纯粹的旧金山人来说，那个错失的机会就是丹尼尔·伯纳姆（Daniel Burnham）的旧金山规划。那是《旧金山纪事报》的建筑评论家约翰·金（John King）。丹尼尔·伯纳姆是一位芝加哥建筑师，他负责监督了1893年芝加哥哥伦比亚博览会“白城”的建设。那次世博会在美国引发了“城市美化运动”。城市美化运动带来了大型市政中心
and grand neoclassical structures that stir the soul. Burnham years later, did the Chicago plan. He did a Washington plan, which was implemented in a lot of ways. Burnham was hired by big time downtown business owners of San Francisco to turn this ragaggedy rickety, but still pretty well off city into something majestic. Who better to chart the course of the city than Daniel Burnham? So Daniel Burnham's team shows up and they set up shop in a cottage on the highest
以及令人心潮澎湃的宏伟新古典主义建筑。多年后，伯纳姆制定了芝加哥规划。他还制定了华盛顿规划，并在许多方面得到了实施。伯纳姆被旧金山的大型市中心企业主聘请，要把这座破旧、摇摇欲坠但依然相当富裕的城市变成宏伟壮丽的城市。还有谁比丹尼尔·伯纳姆更适合为这座城市规划蓝图呢？于是，丹尼尔·伯纳姆的团队出现了，他们在最高点的一间小屋里安营扎寨，
point, the summit of Twin Peaks, so they can survey the city and craft the perfect plan. And here is this plan on how to take San Francisco, the rich, queen city of the gold rush, and the silver rush and so on and so forth, and remake it with this imperial order, with diagonal boulevards connecting all the different neighborhoods of the city, the main hills, telegraph hill, Burnell Heights, Twin Peaks, one or two others, turned into these open civic markers, so on and so forth. You know basically the city as a work of urban art. So Burnham turns on the plan to the Civic Fathers in the fall of 1905.
也就是双子峰（Twin Peaks）的顶峰，这样他们就可以俯瞰全城并制定完美的规划。这就是关于如何将旧金山——这座淘金热、白银热等时期的富饶女王之城——改造成具有帝国秩序的城市的规划，用连接城市各个街区、主要山丘（电报山、伯内尔高地、双子峰等）的对角线大道，将它们变成开放的市政地标等等。你知道，基本上就是把城市当作一件城市艺术品。所以，伯纳姆在1905年秋天向市政元老们提交了这份规划。
You might be able to tell where this is going. There's a big banquet everyone says this is wonderful. The project is printed up in books to distribute to begin making the case. In the legend goes that all the books were delivered to City Hall for distribution on April 17th, 1906. Maybe that's a bit of an insatiation, but basically the whole plan was done, printed up ready for distribution in the 1906 earthquake kits. On the very next day, April 18th. And the city's leveled.
你可能已经猜到接下来会发生什么了。举行了一场盛大的宴会，每个人都说这太棒了。项目被印成书册分发，以开始争取支持。传说所有的书都在1906年4月17日被送到市政厅准备分发。也许这有点夸张，但基本上整个规划已经完成，印好并准备在1906年的地震中分发。就在第二天，4月18日。城市被夷为平地。
And so this is the opportunity. This is San Francisco's chance to enact the Imperial Burnham Plan. And the Chronicle, which was the big paper at the time, embraced it. Everybody said, this is great. Let's bring out Burnham. This is the way to start. And everybody blessed it and endorsed it. But instantly, the plan unraveled.
所以这是一个机会。这是旧金山实施帝国式伯纳姆规划的机会。《纪事报》是当时的大报，它拥护这个规划。每个人都说，这太好了。让我们请出伯纳姆。这是开始的最佳方式。每个人都祝福并支持它。但瞬间，这个规划就瓦解了。
It's something every city ravaged by disaster has seen. There's the way to do it, and there's the way to rebuild quickly. Everyone who had embraced it at first pretty soon they're then saying, well, the business of San Francisco is getting back to business and rebuilding and showing people things. We don't have time to do these crazy things. Burnham and his supporters kept trying to do these crazy things
这是每个遭受灾难蹂躏的城市都见过的情况。有一种做事的方法，还有一种快速重建的方法。起初拥护它的每个人很快就开始说，好吧，旧金山的生意就是恢复生意，重建并向人们展示成果。我们没有时间做这些疯狂的事情。伯纳姆和他的支持者们一直试图做这些疯狂的事情，
from near and far. But none of the real things he proposed stuck at all, because they just, what had seemed to be an opportunity for them to be done, in fact, created the pressure just to go back to the way things were. It's lower Manhattan after 9-11. It's New Orleans after Katrina, again and again and again. So those are two things.
无论远近。但他提出的那些真正的东西一点也没留下来，因为它们只是……原本看起来是一个完成它们的机会，实际上却造成了回归旧模式的压力。就像9/11之后的曼哈顿下城，就像卡特里娜飓风之后的纽奥良，一次又一次。所以这就是两件事。
High speed hanging bullets over the bay, and a logical city, that we can hold in our imaginations and curse our forebearers for being so short-sighted. But quite honestly, a lot of things, in fact probably most of the things that we don't design to build, would have been just terrible. I mean here in the Bay Area alone, there were plenty of near disasters that came this close to becoming a reality. Stuff so bad, you'll make you want to reach out and hug a nimbi, and the culprit in the most terrible plans for the city was the automobile.
海湾上空的高速悬挂子弹头列车，以及一个逻辑化的城市，我们可以将其保留在想象中，并诅咒我们的祖先目光短浅。但老实说，很多事情，实际上可能大多数我们没有设计建造的东西，如果真的建成了会非常糟糕。我的意思是，仅在湾区，就有许多差点成为现实的灾难。那些东西太糟糕了，会让你想去拥抱一个“邻避主义者”（NIMBY），而城市中最糟糕计划的罪魁祸首就是汽车。
They were proposed highway systems that would carve up San Francisco in unimaginable ways, but here they are certainly not alone. The invisible never built parallel universe spans coast to coast. And there are cartographers of these unbuilt worlds. Our producer Sam Greenspan spoke with one of them, a guy who calls himself Venschnuckenragen. I go under the name of Van Schnuckenragen. It doesn't mean anything, it's pure gibberish. My actual name is Andrew Lynch. Van Schnuckenragen, aka Andrew Lynch, is a professional realtor and amateur cartographer in New York
有人提议修建高速公路系统，以不可想象的方式切割旧金山，但他们肯定不是唯一这样做的人。这种隐形的、从未建成的平行宇宙横跨东西海岸。而且有这些未建成世界的制图师。我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）采访了其中一位，一个自称“范·施努肯拉根”（Venschnuckenragen）的人。我用“范·施努肯拉根”这个名字。它没有任何意义，纯粹是胡言乱语。我的真名是安德鲁·林奇（Andrew Lynch）。范·施努肯拉根，也就是安德鲁·林奇，是纽约的一名专业房地产经纪人和业余制图师。
City. And these maps that he made. They, from first glance, look like Google maps of New York City, these maps that he made they from first glance look like Google maps of New York City you have the streets and everything if you've ever looked at a Google map You know exactly what this looks like gray for the landmass blue for the water arterial roads They're yellow if they're side streets. They're white. It's just like any other map except except that The map you're looking at isn't of what's really there the map, except that the map you're looking at isn't of what's really there. Andrews map doesn't represent what is, it represents what almost was.
他制作的这些地图。乍一看，它们看起来像纽约市的谷歌地图。如果你看过谷歌地图，你就知道它看起来是什么样子的：灰色代表陆地，蓝色代表水域，黄色代表干道，白色代表侧街。它就像任何其他地图一样，除了……除了你正在看的地图不是现实中存在的东西。安德鲁的地图不代表“是什么”，它代表“差点是什么”。
What I've done is to draw what Google mouse would look like if Robert Moses had gotten his way in the mid-20th century. Okay, so first we got to talk about Robert Moses, the true power broker of New York. And we know that Robert Moses was the true power broker of New York because the title of Robert Carrows 1100 page biography of him is the power broker. I read it. It's so good. It's daunting, but power through it.
我所做的是画出如果罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）在20世纪中期得逞，谷歌地图会是什么样子。好吧，首先我们得谈谈罗伯特·摩西，纽约真正的权力掮客。我们知道罗伯特·摩西是纽约真正的权力掮客，因为罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）为他写的1100页传记的标题就是《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）。我读过它。它太棒了。虽然艰深，但还是坚持读完了。
It really is worth it. Robert Moses built bridges and beaches and highways and public housing. And he did a lot of the master planning of New York City and its surroundings. He even restructured the city governance, but some of what he's most famous, a really infamous for, is what didn't get built. You see, Robert Moses was a man who loved highways. He wanted to build two highways through Manhattan 1, through downtown, through Soho and Trebekah, and one through Midtown, just south of 34th Street. And that's what Andrew Lynch has drawn into the Google map. What those highways would look like today. Now, if you're thinking, this is totally insane.
这真的很值得。罗伯特·摩西建造了桥梁、海滩、高速公路和公共住房。他负责了纽约市及其周边地区的大部分总体规划。他甚至重组了城市治理，但他最出名——或者说臭名昭著——的是那些没有建成的项目。你看，罗伯特·摩西是一个热爱高速公路的人。他想在曼哈顿修建两条高速公路：一条穿过市中心，穿过苏荷区（Soho）和翠贝卡区（Tribeca）；另一条穿过中城，就在34街以南。这就是安德鲁·林奇画在谷歌地图上的内容。这些高速公路今天看起来会是什么样子。现在，如果你认为这完全是疯了，
Who would actually want this massive, gnarled, perpetual traffic jam through Manhattan? You have to understand what was going on at the time. Manhattan wasn't made for cars, and a lot of people really wanted them, so just like cities today, they were trying to solve the problem of a city that didn't function in the modern era. And also, here's a fun fact, Robert Moses didn't drive. He had drivers who carted him around and then dored the horrible New York traffic for him.
谁会真的想要这条穿过曼哈顿的巨大、扭曲、永恒的交通堵塞带？你必须了解当时的情况。曼哈顿不是为汽车设计的，而很多人确实想要汽车，所以就像今天的城市一样，他们试图解决一个在现代无法运作的城市的问题。还有一个有趣的事实，罗伯特·摩西自己不开车。他有司机载着他到处走，替他忍受纽约可怕的交通。
So he could just sit in the back seat and gaze out the window at the scenery. But for us plebians who have to drive ourselves, these highways probably would have inspired no small amount of terrible anxiety. This was a spaghetti network of on and off ramps, wrapping themselves around buildings. But real talk, driving them probably wouldn't have been too much worse than any other giant highway interchange anywhere else. And like everywhere else, these highways wouldn't have worked. We know now that traffic always expands to fill whatever the capacity. I mean, maybe you could drive from Manhattan to Jersey
所以他可以坐在后座，凝视窗外的风景。但对于我们这些必须自己开车的平民来说，这些高速公路可能会引发不少可怕的焦虑。这是一个由匝道组成的意大利面条网络，缠绕在建筑物周围。但说实话，开车经过它们可能不会比其他任何地方的巨型高速公路立交桥更糟糕。而且像其他地方一样，这些高速公路也不会奏效。我们现在知道，交通总是会扩张以填满任何容量。我的意思是，也许你可以从曼哈顿开车到泽西岛，
like five minutes faster than you could today. But the real tragedy here wouldn't have been the failure of the highway's mission. It's the total catastrophe that would have been left underneath. The Manhattan Expressways would only feel like a slight nuisance if you were in a car. But on the ground, lower Manhattan in particular would be almost unrecognizable.
比今天快五分钟。但真正的悲剧不在于高速公路使命的失败。而在于它在下方留下的彻底灾难。如果你在车里，曼哈顿高速公路只会让你觉得有点烦人。但在地面上，尤其是曼哈顿下城，将变得几乎无法辨认。
It just so happened that when I was talking with Andrew, we were in Lowerman Hatton, right on Varic Street. And as he was telling me about all this unbuilt stuff, I realized that a lot of these things were mere blocks from where we happened to be. I asked Andrew if he can give me a tour of what's not there. Going off, we're walking south. Right in front of us would have been, in fact, if we go down a couple blocks, we could like stand right under it.
碰巧的是，当我和安德鲁交谈时，我们就在曼哈顿下城，就在瓦里克街（Varic Street）上。当他告诉我所有这些未建成的项目时，我意识到其中许多东西距离我们当时所在的地方只有几个街区。我问安德鲁是否能带我参观一下那些“不存在”的东西。我们正向南走。就在我们面前，事实上，如果我们往下走几个街区，我们甚至可以站在它下面。
You can hear the street traffic, but it would have been 10 times worse than this. It would have been dark. It would have been like we were approaching in a very loud sort of monstrous creature. It would have been drenched in darkness right now, smelling exhaust, lots of car noise, you hear that whoosh, that whoosh that you always get next to a highway.
你可以听到街道上的交通声，但那会比现在糟糕十倍。那会是黑暗的。那会像是一个非常吵闹的怪物正在逼近。现在这里会浸透在黑暗中，闻着废气，到处是汽车噪音，你听到了吗，那种你在高速公路旁边总能听到的呼啸声。
There would be these ramps going along these side streets, ramping around buildings. To get from 34 stories in the air, you have to have ramps coming down. You would have the highway itself running down to the west over there. Good luck finding anyone to live or it's worth it. Everywhere you look, buildings literally would have just been surrounded by how it was. A dynamic, filth machine.
会有匝道沿着这些侧街延伸，绕着建筑物盘旋。要从34层楼高的地方下来，你必须有匝道。你会看到高速公路本身就在西边延伸。祝你能找到人住在那里，或者觉得那值得。无论你往哪里看，建筑物字面上都会被高速公路包围。一台动态的污垢机器。
It's a really weird experience trying to, like like take a tour of something it isn't there. It's you have to have a very active imagination, which I do. But if you want to try it find like a highway and just stand under it and then come here and then try to remember what that feels like. Back in the real world, things are quite nice around Lower Manhattan. Where we're standing now, it's open, there's trees over there, there's big buildings right here, none of this was a part. It's a little bit of a plaza, this is a nice diner here, you've got shops, you know, we're looking over there, there's townhouses and tenements that probably are asking way too much for rents because of where we are, that would have nothing. None of this. None of this would be here.
试图参观一个不存在的东西是一种非常奇怪的体验。你必须有非常活跃的想象力，我确实有。但如果你想尝试一下，找一条高速公路，站在它下面，然后来到这里，试着回忆那种感觉。回到现实世界，曼哈顿下城周围的情况相当不错。我们现在站的地方，很开阔，那边有树，这里有大楼，这些都不是那个计划的一部分。这里有一点广场，这里有一家不错的餐馆，你有商店，你知道，我们往那边看，有联排别墅和廉租房，因为我们所处的位置，租金可能高得离谱，如果那个计划实施，这一切都不会存在。这一切都不会在这里。
Which brings us back to Andrew's map of Robert Moses' unbuilt Manhattan. I think what's most striking about these documents is how unstriking they are with their Google standard grays and blues and yellows. Andrew created a map to show how terrible these things would have been. But in creating the map, he was actually able to see the project from the planners point of view. As I went through cutting across Manhattan, before I drew in the highway, I just looked at the swath that I had erased. It was an interesting feeling. I could put myself in Robert Moses' shoes where I'm not looking at a city while I'm doing that.
这让我们回到了安德鲁的罗伯特·摩西未建成曼哈顿地图。我认为这些文档最引人注目的是它们是多么的“不引人注目”，有着谷歌标准的灰色、蓝色和黄色。安德鲁制作了一张地图来展示这些东西会有多糟糕。但在制作地图的过程中，他实际上能够从规划者的角度看待这个项目。当我穿过曼哈顿切割时，在画入高速公路之前，我只是看着我擦除的那片区域。这是一种有趣的感受。我可以把自己放在罗伯特·摩西的位置上，我在做这件事时并没有看着一座城市。
I'm looking at a map. And because I don't see the people and I don't see the homes, I don't see the buildings, it's very tempting to just be like, okay, you just put it right there. You know, not realizing there's a building outlined here. And I can, I know what that building means. That's a place that people live, that people go that I've been to. And now it's off the map. It doesn't exist.
我看着的是一张地图。因为我看不见人，看不见家，看不见建筑物，所以很容易就会想，好吧，你就把它放在那里。你知道，没有意识到这里勾勒出了一栋建筑。我知道那栋建筑意味着什么。那是一个人们居住的地方，人们去过的地方，我也去过的地方。现在它从地图上消失了。它不存在了。
It's funny to hear you describe your own map with like a degree of animosity. I wanted to put this for the everyday person to look at this and say wow, that would have been terrible. I would have loved to be able to make a Google Street view and like put yourself right there so you could in this map stand under the highway, see what it was like, just have this great dark mass above you. The story of how all this didn't come to be is a long one. see what it was like, just have this great dark mass above you. The story of how all of this didn't come to be is a long one. It often centers around an activist named Jane Jacobs, who led a campaign to keep one
听到你用一种敌意来描述你自己的地图，这很有趣。我想把它呈现给普通人看，让他们说“哇，那太糟糕了”。我本来很想制作一个谷歌街景，让你置身其中，这样你就可以在这张地图上站在高速公路下面，看看那是什么样子，感受一下头顶上那巨大的黑暗块。关于这一切是如何没有实现的，故事很长。它通常围绕着一位名叫简·雅各布斯（Jane Jacobs）的活动家，她领导了一场运动，阻止了摩西的一条高速公路摧毁她心爱的街区——格林威治村（Greenwich Village）。
of Moses' highways from destroying her beloved neighborhood, Greenwich Village. And there were other factors like the massive cost of those highways that were proposed that kept them from happening as well. But the interesting part to me is how that threat of the Lower Manhattan Expressway crystallized the story of Jacob's neighborhood. It's almost as if the threat from Moses made Greenwich Village into the place it now seems destined to have become. And that brings us back to the San Francisco Bay area.
还有其他因素，比如提议的高速公路的巨额成本，也阻止了它们的实现。但对我来说，有趣的部分是曼哈顿下城高速公路的威胁是如何让雅各布斯的街区故事变得清晰的。就好像摩西的威胁让格林威治村变成了它现在注定要成为的地方。这又把我们带回了旧金山湾区。
Here's John King and Alison Ariath again. The unbuilt can in fact start what does happen. So if you drive north on the Golden Gate Bridge immediately to your left as you start to reach the end of the bridge, you see a tremendously beautiful hills overlooking the ocean, and then the bay to the other side. And there's nothing built on those hills. It's all natural landscape and there's people biking and walking and it's rolling hills
再次请出约翰·金和艾莉森·阿里亚斯。未建成的项目实际上可以决定后来发生的事情。所以，如果你开车在金门大桥上向北行驶，当你开始到达桥的尽头时，在你的左手边，你会看到俯瞰海洋的极其美丽的山丘，另一边是海湾。那些山上什么也没建。全是自然景观，有人在骑自行车和散步，那是连绵起伏的山丘，
that go all the way out to the headlands. And when you see it for the first time, it's kind of hard to believe that this much open, beautiful landscape exists right next to one of the most expensive cities in the world. And it is kind of remarkable because obviously it would be some of the most prime real estate in the area. In fact, that's in the 60s what someone attempted to do there.
一直延伸到岬角。当你第一次看到它时，很难相信在世界上最昂贵的城市之一旁边，竟然存在着如此多开阔、美丽的景观。这确实非常了不起，因为显然那将是该地区最优质的房地产之一。事实上，这就是60年代有人试图在那里做的事情。
And in the early 60s, a developer thought, what a great place to build 20,000 homes or so for people who are going to work in San Francisco. It was called Marincello. This was not seen as a rapacious idea at the time. This was seen as how business is done. It was a massive mix of houses and towers. And it was approved with very little controversy by the Marin County Board as supervisors.
在60年代初，一位开发商心想，在这里为那些在旧金山工作的人建造大约2万套住宅，该有多好。它被称为“马林塞洛”（Marincello）。在当时，这并不被视为一个贪婪的想法。这被视为商业运作的方式。这是一个巨大的住宅和塔楼混合体。它在马林县监事会几乎没有争议地获得了批准。
But Marincello being approved was enough to alarm people and start people reacting to it. And it led to lawsuits, it led to opposition, it led to local cities starting to fight it. When the dust settled the project did not get built. Apparently the only thing that was built was the gate that was going to lead to the marketing center at the very start of the property. So the Golden Gate National Recreation Area was formed out of concern for all the various plans that were being proposed. Marinchello was blocked, the Sutro-Baz lands end in San Francisco had a proposed kind of can-cune type resort.
但马林塞洛的获批足以引起人们的警觉并开始反抗。它导致了诉讼，导致了反对，导致了当地城市开始抗争。当尘埃落定时，该项目没有建成。显然，唯一建成的是那个原本通往物业入口处营销中心的大门。因此，金门国家游乐区（Golden Gate National Recreation Area）的成立，正是出于对所提议的各种计划的担忧。马林塞洛被阻止了，旧金山的苏特罗浴场（Sutro Baths）和土地尽头（Lands End）曾有一个提议的坎昆式度假村。
And if you are at all familiar with lands end in San Francisco where the Sutro-Bathroom are, you know how silly that notion sounds. It is only cancun as interpreted by the North Pole. You know, so there are various projects like that that what was proposed never got built, but it set the events in motion that in fact determine the landscape we have. What projects like that did in the early 60s is that they were a signal to people who cared about the topography of the Bay Area and the proximity of open space to urbanized space to say, what are we going to do?
如果你对旧金山的土地尽头和苏特罗浴场有任何了解，你就知道这个想法听起来有多愚蠢。那只是北极版诠释的坎昆。所以，有各种各样的项目，提议的从未建成，但它们引发的事件实际上决定了我们今天拥有的景观。60年代初这类项目所做的是，它们向那些关心湾区地形以及开放空间与城市化空间邻近性的人发出了信号，说：我们该怎么办？
We can't fight every one of these battles that comes along. Is there a holistic way to go about it? And you had some very smart people who came up with the idea of, well, what if there was a national park that could take in all this? And Marin Cello may be unbuilt, but to say that there's nothing there in the headlands is not seeing the grand thing. San Francisco actually did build for itself, and everyone else who visits.
我们不能打赢每一场随之而来的战斗。有没有一种整体的方法来处理它？有一些非常聪明的人提出了一个想法：如果有一个国家公园能把所有这些都囊括进去呢？马林塞洛可能没建成，但说岬角那里什么都没有，那是没看到宏伟之处。旧金山确实为自己以及所有来访的人建造了一些东西。
What they actually did build over there was the reason we all love it here. 99% Invisible is Sam Green span Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Julie Kane of K-A-L-W's 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99nipei.org. You must go to 999pi.org. Radio to be on. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们在那里真正建造的东西，正是我们所有人热爱这里的原因。《99%隐形》由萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马斯制作。特别感谢旧金山KALW 91.7本地公共广播电台的朱莉·凯恩（Julie Kane）和旧金山美国建筑师协会。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。你必须访问99pi.org。广播开启。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。